the characters are still alive for the
final chapter of Game of Thrones have
gone through some monumental personal
evolutions but no character has had
quite a shocking a transformation as
bran Stark whose metamorphosis into the
three-eyed Raven rendered him more
cryptic than ever at the start of Game
of Thrones season eight a peculiar line
brannad said during the season premiere
struck viewers as incredibly odd and
people are debating its true meaning
what are you doing out here waiting for
an old friend the final moments of the
Thrones Season 8 premiere seemed to
confirm that the Natsu dear Polly was
anticipating meeting again it was Jaime
Lannister way back in the first episode
Jaime shoved bran out of a Winterfell
tower window when Brandon caught him and
Cersei in the heat of passion when the
two spotted one another from opposite
ends of the Winterfell courtyard in the
present it marks the first time they've
laid eyes on each other since he
incident that left front paralysed
it seemed he sprinkled in some signature
Starks ass and sarcastically calling
Jaime an old friend but some Game of
Thrones fans have a different idea about
what brands comment truly meant one
theory suggests that bran wasn't talking
about Jaime Lannister at all instead the
bran may have been referring to another
man whom he hasn't seen in years
they've also betrayed him and his family
Theon Greyjoy once he rescues his sister
Yara from their uncle the air on Theon
at mid study doesn't want to go back to
the Iron Islands and hold strong it will
be simple to wait out the war between
the White Walkers and the humans of
Westeros and a land that the monsters
can reach but Theon has other plans he
wants to head to Winterfell where film
was awarded to Ned Stark Theo wants to
fight alongside the Starks his second
family you want to go to Winterfell
to fight for the Starks
[Music]
go beyond is absolutely an old friend of
the stark family the unaltered it the
hand that fed him however turning his
back on Robb Stark had joined the war of
the five kings and taking his father
Balin Greyjoy side to carry out an
invasion of the north things were made
even worse than Theon tricked the people
of Winterfell into thinking he burned
bran and his younger brother Rickon
alive after the Greyjoy seized control
of the castle the olds betrayal sent him
on a terrifying journey which saw him
become the tormented servant slash pet
of Ramsay Bolton before escaping by the
skin of his teeth
it's little one that I'm now after
having gone through everything he did
following his double crossing of the
Starks Theon would want to right his
wrongs with the Starks in the game of
Thrones Season 8 trailer bran is heard
welcoming someone home everything you
did Vanity Fair knows that it sounds
like Branagh speaking of Winterfell well
that line could be delivered to Sansa
Arya or John those three are already a
Winterfell and to feel safe there Theon
on the other hand he has struggled to
find this place in the world for many
years and it sure would mean a lot to
hear that he can call Winterfell home
again Theon may be taking his final step
toward Redemption and his imminent
meeting with bran could be what seals
the deal
Theon already has forgiveness from John
who told him during the season 7 finale
that he is just as much as stark as he
is a Greyjoy but receiving absolution
from bran would have me not much more
then again maybe there's no connection
between what brand says in the throne
season a trailer and his old friend line
bran isn't the person he used to be and
has been saying all kinds of strange
stuff since he became the three-eyed
raven for example when Jon hugs him and
tells him he's a man now of bran replies
you're a man almost is he just being
cryptic for the sake of it is he talking
about being in a wheelchair and how that
may cause some to think less of him what
does he mean is something other than
totally human because he's the
three-eyed Raven everything that comes
out of brans mouth can be interpreted a
thousand different ways his comment
about waiting for an old friend is no
exception
with only five episodes of Game of
Thrones remaining bounds will hopefully
find out the truth about brand cryptic
line soon enough check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about game of throne
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]